chercher à l'Observatoire sur le
Moyen-Orient et la chair Raoul
d'endurance à l'UQAM bonsoir madame ziai
les Iraniens continuent de manifester on
le voit au péril de leur vie qu'est-ce
qu'il y a dans le cas particulier de
cette jeune femme qui suscite autant de
colère
écoutez je pense que la population
iranienne est arrivée à une forme de
maturité politique et arriver aussi à un
ras-le-bol généralisé ce que vous voyez
ici c'est vraiment je pense le résultat
de plus de 40 ans de répression de
mesures gouvernementales de mesures
religieuses de mesures strictes qui
commencent à étouffer cette population
dans le cas de cette jeune fille de 22
ans c'est vraiment on ne peut plus en
fait aujourd'hui en 2020 accepter les
acceptables je pense que aujourd'hui
c'est de dire non et de ne plus accepter
ce type de pratique malheureusement
Marsa fait partie d'une longue liste de
victimes avant et on a d'autres et
malheureusement quand vous voyez à
l'heure où je vous parle il y a encore
des victimes de tous les jours parce que
ces jeunes ils manifestent je disais au
péril de leur vie la répression est
terrible absolument on ira vous savez
aller dans l'espace public protester
prendre la parole critiquer de l'État
c'est vraiment au prix de votre vie donc
le danger est partout évidemment il y a
une insécurité là où l'État devrait
garantir la sécurité la paix c'est
plutôt la menace l'insécurité qui règne
c'est un état qui est sous contrôle et
surveillance en permanence aucune espace
si vous voulez ne laisser à la critique
au dialogue à ce type de rendement
indication et ce qui est d'autant plus
intéressant c'est qu'on voit en fait
arriver au devant de la scène des droits
humains et les droits des femmes parce
que c'est aussi ça le cas de Martin
Amini c'est est-ce que c'est des
manifestations qui sont contre le voile
obligatoire et la police des ou bien ce
sont des manifestations qui sont devenus
des manifestations contre le régime tout
simplement c'est les uns et les autres
enfin les revendications si vous voulez
se croisent parce que à la fois
évidemment pour les femmes c'est le
buter contre l'ensemble des lois
discriminatoires à l'égard des femmes le
code vestimentaire fait partie d'une de
ces mesures très strictes très rigide
qui a imposé aux femmes mais évidemment
ce type de revendication va rejoindre
d'autres types de revendications de
redémocratique la liberté d'expression
la liberté d'associations la liberté de
réunion et je bon je pense aussi que les
Iraniens demandent à ce que l'État
prenne des responsabilités et qui
puissent pour une fois assurer peut-être
le contrat social ce contrat social n'a
jamais été respecté l'état après 40 ans
plus de 40 ans de règne la situation
économique et désastreuse l'espace
politique est fermé les questions
sociales le bien-être en fait si vous
voulez n'est tout simplement plus
garanti et à ça s'ajoute en plus la
seule la réponse de l'État qui a une
répression forte brutale et une violence
complètement institutionnalisée à tous
les niveaux de la société et est-ce que
ces manifestations-là vont finir par
ébranler le pouvoir ou pas ce que ça
démontre en tout cas c'est que le régime
ne sont plus avoir de légitimité il y a
plus de crédibilité aujourd'hui et
l'ensemble des manifestations qu'on peut
voir ça démontre en fait une véritable
rupture entre la société et l'État entre
donc il y a un décalage en fait entre la
société complètement veut plus de
liberté plus de démocratie absolument
c'est une population qui est éduquée
avec une forme d'éducation vient de
nouvelles aspirations les Iraniens
demandent depuis très longtemps un
processus de démocratisation vous savez
il y a eu le Mouvement Vert en 2009 il y
a eu la campagne d'un million de
signatures en 2006 justement c'était
pour lutter contre les lois
discriminatoires contre les femmes il y
a depuis des années maintenant on a la
campagne le mercredi blanc ça fait un
mois aussi qui lutter contre le port
obligatoire du voile en Iran et j'en
passe il y a eu énormément de campagnes
de mobilisation des actions collectives
des protestations des revendications
mais malheureusement
on voit que à chaque fois que il y a ce
type de manifestation dans l'espace
public mais aussi dans l'espace
spirituel on voit que c'est la
répression et ça la répression
institutionnalisée la répression
étatique qui est la réponse qui est
donnée par l'État est-ce qu'il y a
quelque chose de particulier dans
celle-ci qui peut donner un certain
espoir que le régime peut être ébranlé
d'une certaine façon est-ce qu'il peut
faire des compromis sur le voile par
exemple j'aimerais vous dire oui
j'aimerais y croire comme je pense
beaucoup d'Iraniens souhaitent en fait
qui ait un véritablement un vrai
changement malheureusement si on fait le
bilan des autres mouvements de
protestation on voit qu'à chaque fois
même si malheureusement il y a eu cet
élan il y a eu ce sentiment de révolte
il y a eu ce risque que les uns et les
autres prennent au détriment de leur vie
malheureusement on voit que à chaque
fois ce genre de mouvement est vraiment
écrasé et tout fait
il y a quand même un écho à toutes ces
manifestations un peu partout dans le
monde en vue des manifestations encore
ce soir à Montréal et ça est-ce que
c'est important est-ce que ça peut
mettre la pression sur le régime c'est
important parce que ça le montre aussi
la solidarité entre l'Iran et
l'extérieur parfois les Iraniens peuvent
se sentir isolés déjà c'est un pays qui
est très isolé au niveau international
parfois la population iranienne se sont
oubliées je pense que ce type de
mobilisation vient rappeler que non on
est on défend beaucoup de pays
aujourd'hui des pays
occidentaux et aussi la communauté
iranienne à l'extérieur du pays défense
elle va leur démocratique et cette forme
de solidarité je pense c'est absolument
nécessaire et c'est vraiment d'avoir
cette collectivité ce nous en fait face
à ce e face à un seul État qui se
mobilise et qui finalement souligne
qu'on peut plus accepter l'inacceptable
merci beaucoup d'être venu nous en
parler je pense que c'est important de
faire le point et de suivre ce qui se
passe dans votre pays d'origine merci
pour cette visibilité merci de donner la
voix aussi on va merci